- So the Lincoln Project
has accused Rudy Giuliani
of defaming them in an
interview with Steve Bannon.
- The defense is going to have to show
that this thing was planned
and that a lot of the people
involved in the planning,
ANTIFA, and then even
some right-wing groups
were enemies of his, and
that they were doing it
in order to hurt him,
including some right-wing groups
that operate for the Lincoln Project.
- Reminder, Rudy would have to say
some objectively
verifiable, false statement
about the Lincoln Project.
This is pretty broad so far.
- One of the people involved
brought in right-wing
groups that opposed Trump.
He had the same motivation
the ANTIFA people had.
And the biggest problems,
violent problems,
were caused by ANTIFA.
That's where the shooting took place.
- I mean, that's completely false, but,
you know, Rudy is just
gonna make stuff up.
- But who is the guy working
with the Lincoln Project?
- I don't know if I can reveal his name,
because we have have that
from anonymous sources.
- When Steve Bannon is laughing at you,
you know you're a complete wacko
and you've lost the room here.
I'm not sure that this
gives rise to defamation.
Also, what damages would
the Lincoln Project
have suffered here?
If the Lincoln project does
follow through with this,
this is going to be
performative litigation,
the kind that I hate from
both sides of the aisle.
But anyway, subscribe,
or I'll see you in court.